I see coach the girl seen covered in
blood in this video after she says she
was beaten by a mob at chavala
Nehru University in New Delhi is the one
now under investigation the police have
registered a legal complaint against her
and 26 others accusing them of vandalism
on the University campus the day before
the attack but only one complaint on a
crowd of 50 seen hitting the students
with iron bars this student says he was
also beaten up but doesn't want to worry
his parents by revealing his identity
police go Pontianak and polish from
kovala when I called the police they ask
me what is Jawaharlal Nehru University
where is it they didn't help us instead
they facilitated the exit of the goons
some people including lawyer Mangla now
suspect police let the attack happen and
allowed the street lights to be switched
off outside the campus so those
responsible could not be identified the
lights in the adjoining streets were all
on so so the lights were definitely off
and when we were there by around 12
o'clock the light suddenly came on so
it's not it definitely can't be a hitch
glitch in the system or something
because anywhere else it was late
Mangala says activists and journalists
were assaulted and taunted outside the
campus as the police watched
the students who were beaten up say many
of their attackers were from the ABVP
a student's union affiliated with the
governing Hindu nationalist BJP but the
ABVP denies it was behind the attack and
instead says its members were the ones
beaten out earlier that day the police
say they have launched an investigation
investigation a senior officers the
crime branch and local police visited
the attack site and we found vital clues
so we are working on that and hopefully
we will crack this case soon since the
government passed the new citizenship
law police have opened fire on
protesters in Uttar Pradesh smashed
motorbikes and illegal and beaten up
students from Jamia Millia Islamia
University in New Delhi now many
students at this university in the
capital say it's clear the police are
working against them
Archer wara al Jazeera New Delhi